In this video I want to take a look
several examples of data presented in different ways,
and to think which one is the best.
Or which one can help us answer different questions.
Let's see the first example.
A statistician recorded the length of each one
from the first 14 films of Pixar.
He made a point chart, each point being a movie,
histogram and box-type diagram,
to show movie length data.
Which way of exposing the data can be used,
to find the median?
Let's look at these modes of presentation.
Here we see the point graph.
We have a point for each of the 14 films.
One movie lasts 81 minutes.
We see that there.
Another had a duration of 92.
Third - 93.
We see that one was with a duration of 95.
And two had a duration of 96 minutes,
and so on, etc.
I say that I can use this to find the median,
because I can list each of the lengths
of movies, I can arrange them
and then I can find the median.
I can literally make a list.
I can write 81 and then 92,
then write 93, then 95,
then I can write 96 twice,
and then I can write 98,
then I can write 100.
I think you understand where the things are going.
I can write the whole list
and then I can find the value in the middle.
So I can use the point chart to find the middle.
But what about the histogram?
Here's the histogram.
Here the way to find the median is
just to work
with a list of numbers.
Here is a movie,
which is between 80 and 85 minutes,
but I do not know its exact duration.
Its duration may have been 81 minutes,
or it may have been 84 minutes.
Here I do not know and I can not actually list myself
of the length of the films
and find the median.
No, I do not think I can
to do it by using a histogram.
On box type diagram here ...
So I will not mark the histogram.
On the box type diagram here
I may not be able to list all the values,
but the box-type chart clearly shows me what the median is.
The vertical line in the box
shows us the median. How is this?
If this is 100, this median is 99.
So it's 95, 96, 97, 98, 99.
It clearly shows us that the median is 99.
This is actually the easiest way to calculate the median.
So I will choose the box type diagram.
For me, the histogram is useless,
if I want to calculate the median.
Let's solve some of these tasks.
We have a place with used cars.
He checks the mileage of the cars
and records how many kilometers they have been driving.
He then creates a histogram and a box-type diagram,
to provide the same data, both of which are shown below.
Which data representation can be used,
to find out how many cars have been driven
more than 200,000 kilometers?
So, how many cars have been driven
It seems here in this histogram
I have 3 cars that were between 200 and 250,
then I have 2 cars that are between 250 and 300.
It seems quite clear that there are 5 cars,
three that ranged between 200,000 and 250,000,
and then I have 2 that have passed
between 250,000 and 300,000.
Now I can answer the question.
5 cars have gone over 200,000 kilometers.
I can say that the histogram is quite useful.
But let's prove that the box-type diagram is not so useful.
I want to know how many cars are spinning
more than 200,000.
Well, I know that if we have more than 200,000,
we will be in the fourth quarters,
but we do not know how many values ​​there are,
just by looking at this data here,
so this will not be useful to answer this question.
Let's look at the second question.
Which presentation can be used,
to find the value of the median,
which mode of presentation can be used to find,
that the value of the median
is approximately 140,000 kilometers?
To find the median,
you can basically list all the numbers
and then find the number in the middle.
And here we can not count all the numbers.
I know there are 3 values ​​that are
between 0 and 50,000 kilometers,
but I do not know who they are.
There may be 10,000, 10,000, 10,000.
There may be 10,000, 15,000 and 40,000.
I do not know what they are, so if I can not list them all
these things and sort them,
I will really have difficulty in finding the value of the median.
The value of the median will be
in this range somewhere here,
but I do not know exactly how much it will be.
The histogram is not useful,
because we have put all the values ​​in these groups.
While chart-type box clear,
directly shows us the value of the median.
This line is here inside the box
shows us the value of the median,
and we see that the value of the median here,
is 140,000 kilometers.
This is 100, 110, 120, 130,
140,000 km is the median value of the distance traveled by the cars.
So the box-type diagram
clearly shows us this data.